GEORGE CONWAY ALONG WITH ELLIOT
WILLIAMS.
THEY BOTH JOIN ME, FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR AND FORMER
DEPUTY ASSISTANT ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
GEORGE, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
CHARGES BEING INVESTIGATED HERE
TONIGHT AND THE LIST OF WHAT WAS
TAKEN AS FAR AS YOU CAN GO
THROUGH IT, AND THERE'S A LOT OF
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION ON THERE,
DO YOU THINK TRUMP'S IN REAL
TROUBLE HERE?
>> YEAH, I THINK HE'S IN VERY
SUBSTANTIAL LEGAL JEOPARDY.
IF ANYBODY ELSE HAD DONE THIS,
AS I SAID LAST NIGHT ON YOUR
SHOW, IF A NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR HAD DONE THIS, IF AN
ASSISTANT TO THE PRESIDENT HAD
DONE, THIS IF I HAD DONE THIS OR
YOU HAD DONE THIS, WE'D PROBABLY
BE ALREADY CHARGED.
HAVING TOP SECRET AND TOP SECRET
SCI INFORMATION IN OUR HOME?
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO BRING THAT
OUT.
HOME.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN CHARGED FOR A
LOT LESS.
THERE WAS A WOMAN LAST YEAR IN A
VERY HIGHLY PUBLICIZED CASE, SHE
WAS A CIVILIAN IN THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT AND SHE WAS DETAILED
TO THE U.S. EMBASSY IN MANILA.
AND SHE TOOK HOME TO HER BEDROOM
A COUPLE OF JUST ACADEMIC THESIS
THAT WERE LABELED SECRET AND SHE
WAS CHARGED WITH A CRIME.
SHE WAS ONLY USING IT TO USE AS
MODELS FOR HER OWN CLASSIFIED
THESIS.
BUT THE FACT SHE TOOK THEM HOME
TO HER BEDROOM GOT HER THREE
MONTHS IN PRISON.
>> THREE MONTHS IN PRISON.
SO, ELIOTT, LET'S GO THROUGH
THIS.
THE SEARCH WARRANT IDENTIFIES
THREE POTENTIAL FEDERAL CRIMES
THAT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
INVESTIGATING DONALD J. TRUMP
FOR.
THEY ARE VIOLATIONS OF THE
ESPIONAGE ACT, OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE, AND CRIMINAL HANDLING
OF GOVERNMENT RECORDS.
SO, ELLIOT, WE'RE GETTING A
LITTLE CONTEXT FROM GEORGE WITH
THAT EXAMPLE FROM MANILA, THREE
MONTHS IN PRISON FOR THAT
INDIVIDUAL.
HOW SERIOUS ARE THESE POTENTIAL
VIOLATIONS?
>> THEY'RE INCREDIBLY SERIOUS.
PEOPLE HEAR THE ESPIONAGE ACT
AND THINK OF CLOAK AND DAGGER
AND TRENCH COATS AND SPIES
OVERSEAS.
IT'S A FAR BROADER ACT THAN
THAT, WRITTEN I THINK 100 YEARS
AGO AND COVERS REALLY THE
MISHANDLING AND BAD STORAGE OF
INFORMATION THAT COULD CAUSE
HARM TO THE UNITED STATES.
PARTICULARLY WITH RESPECT TO THE
DOCUMENTS AND PICKING UP ON SOME
OF THE POINTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE HERE, YOU KNOW, THE
LANGUAGE -- THE DEFINITION OF
TOP SECRET INFORMATION IS
INFORMATION THAT COULD CAUSE
EXCEPTIONALLY GRAVE HARM TO THE
UNITED STATES IF DISCLOSED.
AND SO NONE OF THIS BELONGS EVEN
FOR A FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IN AN UNSECURE
LOCATION OUT OF SOMEONE'S HOME.
SO ANY OF THESE THREE CRIMES,
AND WE CAN WALK THROUGH EACH OF
THEM, BUT ANY OF THEM, NUMBER
ONE CARRIES SERIOUS PENALTIES
AND IS FOCUSED ON SOMETIMES
GROSS NEGLIGENCE IN JUST
MISHANDLING INFORMATION.
IT'S INCREDIBLY SERIOUS, WHETHER
IT'S THE PRESIDENT OR SOMEBODY
ELSE WHO MIGHT HAVE BEEN
INVESTIGATED HERE WHO MIGHT BE
PULLED IN HERE.
>> SO, GEORGE, LET ME ASK YOU
BECAUSE KASH PATEL, EVAN WAS
SHARING WHAT HE IS PUTTING OUT
AS THE DEFENSE FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
HE'S NOW SAYING THAT, OH, WELL,
IT WAS AN ACCIDENT.
WE HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH IT OF
HOW THESE DOCUMENTS ENDED UP
HERE.
HERE'S WHAT HE JUST SAID ON FOX
NEWS.
>> THE GSA HAS SINCE COME OUT,
THE GOVERNMENT SERVICE
ADMINISTRATION AND SAID THEY
MISTAKENLY PACKED SOME BOXES AND
MOVED THEM TO MAR-A-LAGO.
THAT'S NOT ON THE PRESIDENT.
THAT'S ON THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES
TO SORT THAT MATERIAL OUT.
>> SO, GEORGE, THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES HAVE BEEN TRYING TO GET
THESE DOCUMENTS BACK FROM TRUMP
FOR 15 MONTHS.
THEY ASKED FOR THEM.
THEY NEGOTIATED, THEY SENT SOME
BACK, BUT NOT ALL OF THEM.
THEY REALIZED SOME WERE MISSING.
THEY GAVE HIM A SUBPOENA, THEY
SENT SOME MORE BACK.
AND NOW HERE WE ARE.
SO HOW IS IT POSSIBLE FOR ANYONE
TO ARGUE THAT THERE WASN'T SOME
VERY SPECIFIC PURPOSEFUL
DECISIONS MADE ABOUT HOLDING
THESE DOCUMENTS BACK?
>> YEAH, THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRYING TO DEFEND TRUMP ARE
BASICALLY DESPERATE.
THEY HAVE BEEN MAKING ALL SORTS
OF INSANE ARGUMENTS, ARGUING
THAT THE FBI PLANTED DOCUMENTS,
ARGUING THAT SOMEHOW, YOU KNOW,
LIKE CARMAC THE MAGNIFICENT HE
HELD THEM TO HIS FOREHEAD AND
DECLASSIFIED THEM LIKE THAT.
NONE OF THIS MAKES ANY SENSE AT
ALL.
HE HAD THESE DOCUMENTS.
HE HAD THEM FOR A LONG TIME.
IN ORDER TO HAVE TAKEN THEM FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE, HE PROBABLY
BROUGHT THEM UP TO THE
RESIDENCE.
HE HAD NO BUSINESS BRINGING TOP
SECRET SCI MATERIALS FROM THE
SITUATION ROOM OR OVAL OFFICE UP
TO THE RESIDENCE.
HE HAD NO BUSINESS HAVING THESE
DOCUMENTS.
AND AS SOON AS THE ARCHIVES
POINTED THAT OUT, EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THEM SHOULD HAVE BEEN
RETURNED TO THE GOVERNMENT, AND
HE DIDN'T DO THAT.
THAT FALLS SQUARELY UNDER THE
PROHIBITION OF SECTION 793 AND
THE ESPIONAGE ACT.
>> ERIN, IF I CAN ADD TO THAT A
LITTLE BIT.
I HAD TOP SECRET CLEARANCE FOR
PRETTY MUCH MY ENTIRE TIME AT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AT A
PRETTY HIGH LEVEL.
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF DOCUMENTS
THAT JUST DON'T GET MISPACKED OR
PUT INCORRECTLY AS KASH PATEL
SAID THERE IN THE BACK OF A
TRUCK.
THERE'S EXTENSIVE REGULATIONS ON
HOW THEY'RE HANDLED, WHAT KIND
OF ROOM THEY'RE IN, WHO CAN
HANDLE THEM.
HOW THEY'RE SHREDDED.
THERE'S REGULATIONS ON THE KIND
OF SHREDDER THAT CAN BE USED TO
DESTROY INFORMATION ONCE IT'S NO
LONGER -- ONCE IT CAN BE
DESTROYED.
SO THIS IDEA THAT SOMEBODY JUST
MADE A MISTAKE AND PACKED
SOMETHING ON THE WRONG TRUCK AND
ENDED UP AT MAR-A-LAGO IS JUST
LUDICROUS.
WHAT YOU HAVE IN A SEARCH
T
WARRANT IS AN INDICATION THAT
SOMEONE, NUMBER ONE A FEDERAL
JUDGE AND LAW ENFORCEMENT, H